with all due respect to your question
this is frivolous this is a diversionary
tactic hey guys I'm off the grid for
August and here's me doing an impression
of Nancy Pelosi because she did a little
of this how do you feel about the push
by the House Republicans many of them
speaker is certainly you know flirted
with this idea of impeachment
proceedings against
you know President Biden because of
unfounded allegations that he was
involved with his son Hunter's
businesses
you well know as you were very cautious
about starting impeachment proceedings
for the very reason that once you start
in a special committee or the Judiciary
Committee it's very hard to stop that
process
well let's with all due respect to your
question this is frivolous this is a
diversionary tactic they just can't
stand the fact that we had a job report
of over nearly 200 000 jobs today that
unemployment is three and a half percent
the 18 straight months of unemployment
being under four percent we're talking
about
13.4 million jobs created as with Joe
Biden in the White House and working
with the Congressional Democrats they to
change the subject and they have nothing
to offer the American people in terms of
jobs and the rest they talk about it but
then they change the subject when it's
time to deliver I'm so proud of the
Democrats and the Congress we fully
intend to take back the house the next
time so we don't have to deal with the
frivolity
the waste of time of the Congress for
them to to go down this path it's really
sad I wish I wish the Republican Party
would be somebody would take it back
that we'd have a real Republican party
it's up to them to decide what it is but
it shouldn't be a cult
it shouldn't be a cult to somebody
frivolous with the law and his uh
puppets
is there anything in terms of procedure
that house Democrats can do to stop it
from happening if they decide to vote
for starting the impeachment process
public sentiment if they want to subject
with their members who are in a
difficult districts
subject them to that
bring it on just bring it on it's not
going to go anyplace they can't uh
they're going to undo the other
impeachments they can't do that but they
can talk about it